mes chers
de votre présence ce matin pour cette
nouvelle réunion de la délégation à la
prospective
donc ce matin nous nous retrouvons pour
discuter évoquer un sujet jusqu'à lors
méconnu
j'en étude de notre de notre délégation
même si on reste sur la thématique de la
ressource mais après avoir parlé de
l'eau et nous rendrons le 24 novembre
prochain ce rapport sur l'avenir de
l'eau passons maintenant au thème de
l'exploitation des ressources spatiales
et d'abord des ressources de la lune
puisque il n'aura échappé à personne que
les Américains entendent d'y retourner
d'ici à 2035 dans le cadre de la mission
Artemis c'est que les Chinois associés
russes n'entendent nullement se laisser
distancer sur sur ce terrain là la lune
donc pourrait bel et bien offrir des
ressources exploitables dans un premier
temps en appui direct aux missions
d'exploration pour fabriquer n'est pas
de la science-fiction plusieurs projets
concret sont déjà lancés j'y faisais
référence les États-Unis et la Chine
sont entrés dans la course et des
entreprises privées travaillent à des
solutions utiles à relativement court
terme nous aurions tort de ne pas
prendre tout cela au sérieux la dernière
fois c'était à propos des lanceurs
réutilisables d'Elon musk bref
l'exploitation des ressources spatiales
c'est un sujet de prospective par
définition par excellence si j'ose dire
encore assez loin de nous pour qu'on
puisse tout imaginer mais déjà assez
proche pour qu'on puisse le faire avec
rigueur et réalisme c'est sur ce sujet
que vont travailler nos deux collègues
qui sont à côté de moi et que je salue
Christine Lavarde et Vanina paoligajin
dans le cadre du rapport qui leur a été
confié l'audition de ce matin qui porte
spécifiquement comme je l'ai dit sur la
lune constitue en quelque sorte le
lancement de nos travaux mais qu'il
s'agisse l'exploitation des ressources
ou du reste chacun sait que la Lune un
premier pas vers Mars et sur mon plus
loin encore sur ce sujet comme celui sur
un sujet pardon comme celui-ci quel est
le regard des chercheurs celui des
grandes agences gouvernementales celui
encore des entreprises c'est en quelque
sorte pour croiser ces différents points
de vue que nous avons le plaisir de
recevoir nos invités ce matin commencez
par Madame Isabelle sourbaise verger
spécialiste de géopolitique spatiale et
directrice de recherche au CNRS madame
Pascal
ultra Guérard qui est directrice
adjointe des programmes du Centre
national d'études spatiale madame
clarissan gelier qui est délégué général
de l'Association Nationale de la
Recherche et de la Technologie et enfin
Monsieur Alban Guyomar
doctorant en droit coordinateur du
travail Objectif Lune au sein de cette
agence nationale de la recherche de la
technologie dans le rapport a été publié
en juin dernier mais avant de vous
laisser la parole je souhaitais laisser
Christine Navarre et Vanina paoliagin
ajouté quelques mots en guise
d'introduction mesdames je vous cède la
part merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues effectivement cette première
audition en commun sur un sujet sur
lequel nous avons commencé à travailler
avec Vanina va pouvoir nous donner
l'occasion de vous expliquer un peu
l'angle sous lequel nous considérons ce
sujet alors pour ma part moi je souhaite
insister sur la dimension géopolitique
du sujet en effet si l'exploitation
effective des ressources spatiales n'est
pas pour demain elles s'envisage dès
aujourd'hui or tout ceci arrive dans un
contexte bien particulier qui ne vous a
pas échappé de renouveau des tensions
internationales de militarisation de
l'espace de retour des rapports de force
au détriment de la coopération
on l'a bien vu avec la guerre en Ukraine
qui a conduit à la remise en cause de
plusieurs programmes importants et
encore ceci n'est-il pas grand chose au
regard de la rivalité entre les
États-Unis et la Chine qui structurent
chaque jour un peu plus la question
spatiale la course à l'exploitation des
ressources spatiales fait partie de
cette nouvelle équation géopolitique il
y a des signes qui ne trompent pas par
exemple lorsque les Américains décident
dans le cadre des accords Artemis
d'instituer des zones de sécurité sur la
lune afin je cite de réduire les
interférences ou les conflits entre les
opérations rivales de ce point de vue il
y a sans doute quelques enseignements à
tirer du cas de la première des
ressources spatiales la vraie ressource
rare ou bien le rival comme disent les
économistes l'orbite basse cet espace de
plus en plus encombré avec l'essor des
constellations et l'augmentation
exponentielle des débris spatiaux en
principe la seule manière de préserver
cette ressource ce sont la coopération
et la régulation pour autant on ne peut
pas dire que les résultats soient très
satisfaisants en dépit des efforts
depuis longtemps au niveau international
au sein du copuos dont nous avons eu la
chance d'entendre l'ancien président
Gérard brécheret lors de la réunion
interparlementaire sur l'espace qui
s'est tenu au septembre au Sénat alors
comment cela va-t-il se passer pour les
autres ressources spatiales celles qu'on
pourrait exploiter sur la lune ou sur
mars en tout cas le copyos vient de nous
tout juste de saisir officiellement de
la question que l'on pourrait résumer
ainsi le droit de l'espace est-il prêt
pour l'exploitation des ressources où
sommes-nous pour ainsi dire dans un
nouveau Far West avec des mines d'or des
cowboys mais pas vraiment de shérif
merci
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues notre collègue Christine
lavardte vient d'évoquer les aspects
politiques et juridiques de ce sujet
mais il comporte aussi et je
souhaiterais vraiment insister sur ce
point une forte dimension économique
avec les ressources spatiales on parle
bien d'exploitation et non plus
seulement d'exploitation de l'espace
c'est important car ceci revient à
admettre qu'il puisse y avoir dans tout
cela une logique commerciale
ce qui suppose une forme de rentabilité
pour les entreprises qui présupposent
une viabilité de modèles économiques et
puis un retour sur investissement
car infini c'est bien cette approche qui
permettra de faire le tri entre les
projets dit réalistes et ceux qui
relèveraient exclusivement de la
science-fiction
aux États-Unis dire cela serait dire
l'évidence
et c'est bien dans cette perspective que
se positionne tous les acteurs du new
space
sans parler des Chinois qui comptent sur
le spatial pour revendiquer leur
supériorité on l'a vu il y a quelques
jours seulement avec Tiangong
ils y vont pourquoi parce qu'ils pensent
qu'il y a un business
en France pays de Méliès et aussi en
Europe en revanche ou la politique
spatiale est traditionnellement conduite
au nom d'objectifs plus noble comme la
connaissance scientifique ou encore le
progrès humain cela revient nous devons
en convenir à s'attaquer à une forme de
tabou
cela me semble pourtant nécessaire car
le plus difficile ce n'est pas d'évoquer
le tabou c'est
tout ce que ça levait provoque toutes
les questions qu'elle suscite et
auxquelles nous devrons essayer ensemble
de répondre
comment favoriser l'innovation
quel rôle pour les grandes entreprises
quel rôle pour les startups pour les
acteurs du spatial et pour les autres je
pense par exemple aux compagnies
minières dont le savoir-faire pourrait
si je peux m'exprimer ainsi être très
précieux en la matière quid de la
politique de concurrence quid de la
commande publique quel régime de
propriété sur la lune quel régime de
responsabilité sur Mars
tous nos débats d'ici-bas sur la
souveraineté économique sur la
souveraineté industrielle et
technologique de notre pays et de
l'Europe
ce projet en quelque sorte là haut la
question est de savoir si oui ou non
nous souhaitons y avoir une place je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup je vais maintenant céder
la parole à nos intervenants en
commençant par Madame Isabelle sourbesse
verger merci
voilà c'est parfait voilà vous
m'entendez mieux voilà effectivement je
suis géographe je ne fais pas que de la
géopolitique spatiale je fais de la
géographie de l'occupation de l'espace
et effectivement bien sûr une partie de
géographie politique sur quelques-uns
des enjeux que vous avez évoqué en
introduction alors là pardon diapositive
suivante j'appuie gentiment sur mon ça
sert pas à grand chose puisque c'est pas
moi qui est là-bas voilà
la question c'était je suis très
heureuse que vous évoquiez ça en
introduction la question de l'occupation
de l'espace et finalement depuis peu
rentré dans les préoccupations des
chercheurs en sciences humaines et
sociales d'ailleurs je suis la seule
géographie à travailler sur ce sujet en
France ce qui vu mon âge n'est pas sans
poser quelques problèmes dans l'avenir
cette question de l'occupation de
l'espace elle a été tenue à l'écart
parce que finalement la géographie est
bien effectivement c'est l'analyse de la
terre mais si vous regardez un petit peu
cette projection que vous évoquez sur
les orbites basses on voit bien des
activités humaines qui sortent de
l'enveloppe terrestre alors certes en
géographie nos étudiants les relations
entre les hommes et le milieu pour le
dire très très sommairement et
effectivement les hommes dans l'espace
il y en a pas beaucoup il y en a
quelques-uns mais il y en a pas beaucoup
ce sont surtout des engins artificiels
envoyés par l'homme ils n'empêche que et
ça je trouve ça intéressant en 1956 donc
avant le lancement du premier Spoutnik
il y avait un géographe assez atypique
Jean Gotman qui expliquait que
finalement il y aura forcément une
géographie de l'espace dans la mesure où
dès qu'il y a un certain niveau
d'activité les hommes se saisissent de
ce milieu et donc on retombe sur les
sujets que vous évoquez aussi bien celui
de la compétitivité économique que celui
de la compétitivité géopolitique
simplement ce qui est intéressant dans
cette remarque c'est que finalement il
ne consommait pas autre chose que la
Lune c'est à dire que pour lui la
géographie de l'espace qui pouvait se
faire qui devait se faire était une
géographie non pas comme moi je suis
amenée à la faire parce que c'est là
qu'il y a le plus d'activités des
orbites basses mais d'un point d'ancrage
qui était celui de la lune alors je veux
bien la diapose suivante voilà et la
Lune c'est finalement ce seul point que
nous avons quand nous essayons de nous
projeter et d'imaginer une activité
pérenne complète or en réalité je vais
vous montrer que il y a bien d'autres
activités entre la Terre et la Lune donc
j'ai choisi juste quelques illustrations
parce que je trouve qu'elle se marque
les esprits d'abord j'ai rappelé quand
même que la première photo de la face
cachée de la lune elle date de 1959 et
qu'elle est soviétique donc on a
beaucoup parlé de la mission chinoise
qui a consisté et ses différents à poser
un Rover sur la face cachée nous sommes
d'accord mais en fait cette première
vision de la lune c'est une vision
soviétique et on voit bien quand même
l'amélioration de la qualité des
capteurs et des images parce que
effectivement c'était une découverte
puisque personne n'avait jamais vu la
face cachée par définition mais ça
restait quand même une qualité très
éloignée de ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
et puis Neil Armstrong sur la lune qui
marque ce début en quelque sorte par les
États-Unis de l'appréhension de la Lune
comme étant réellement leur nouvelle
frontières c'est à dire que certes le
drapeau a été planté au nom de
l'humanité c'était un grand pas pour
l'homme etc mais quelque part les
États-Unis qui n'ont pas la même
politique de colonisation et la même
histoire de colonisation que nous
pouvons l'avoir en Europe considèrent
vraiment spontanément que leur extension
dans l'espace est une extension
totalement naturelle et historique et
puis à côté j'ai mis un petit dessin que
je trouvais sympathique de Paul-Émile
Victor qui à cette époque sur
l'Antarctique salut son autre humain sur
la lune et là encore on est dans cette
espèce d'idée qui est une idée fausse je
le crains du fait que des activités sur
la lune peuvent un petit peu se passer
comme les activités sur terre parce
qu'en réalité le milieu hostile quel
espace ne permet absolument pas de se
projeter l'Antarctique n'est déjà pas un
milieu très amical mais on est encore
bien loin sur la Lune ne serait-ce que
parce qu'il y a peut-être de l'eau mais
il faut la récupérer en tout cas
certainement pas d'air qu'il faudra
fabriquer et finalement par rapport à
cette ancienne vision je dirais la
nouvelle aujourd'hui qui est cette carte
alors qui date de 2020 qui est une
synthèse de beaucoup de données
américaines et en particulier japonaise
qui montre véritablement la carte
géologique de la lune et qui va nous
servir de base à cette idée d'une
exploitation des ressources minières
avec bien sûr une grande question c'est
comment on forme et comment on récupère
cette ressource et donc quelle est la
valeur de la ressource parce qu'une
ressource finalement géographique c'est
un sujet qu'on connaît bien mais il n'a
que la valeur qu'on lui prête c'est à
dire le besoin qu'on en a et ça ça va
être à mon sens une grande question
qu'il faut se poser sur la Lune je veux
bien la diapose suivante voilà c'est ce
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure si vous
regardez la droite de ma planche vous
voyez la terre au loin vue par une
mission chinoise qui faisait un test
avant de se poser sur la Lune et on voit
bien quand même ce petit point bleu qui
révèle toute cette prise de conscience
des années 70 déjà avec l'émission
Apollo et le début en quelque sorte de
la sensibilisation à l'écologie au
vaisseau terre et à la planète donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui me paraît
toujours important parce que quand on va
discuter j'y reviendrai tout à fait à la
fin des relations Terre-Lune je pense
que cette dimension de préservation on
va aussi la retrouver en effet flashback
sur peut-être une certaine perception
par le public de la nécessité aussi de
préserver la lune aussi une hospitalière
soit elle et à côté et bien vous avez
effectivement alors c'est un schéma
c'est plutôt un élément pour moi mais
finalement je l'ai trouvé assez parlant
vous voyez au centre le petit rond jaune
qui représente l'activité par les
satellites autour de la Terre et vous
voyez autour la distance la lune la
distance moyenne à la lune de 400000 km
donc ce que vous constatez c'est
qu'effectivement et bien l'activité
humaine dans les orbites je vais jusqu'à
l'orbite géostationnaire qui est
l'extérieur de mon œuf au plat là et
effectivement vous vous rendez bien
compte que l'activité elle est écuyée
répartie donc ça représente pas chacun
satellite mais en revanche en densité
mon ma valeur est exacte vous voyez bien
certaines zones plus peuplées que les
autres qui sont les zones des orbites
des satellites à défilement par exemple
autour de la Terre l'orbite des
satellites géostationnaires beaucoup
plus loin et entre les deux des espaces
vides ce qui là aussi sur la question de
la gestion du trafic pose un certain
nombre de questions la question du
trafic ne se pose pas partout de la même
façon dans l'espace donc je la planche
suivante voilà donc la Lune est mars ce
sont des destinations familières mais
qui n'ont pas été finalement tellement
visitées et sur ce graphique
chronologique j'ai représenté toutes les
missions qui ont eu lieu vers la lune et
vers Mars avec les nationalités des
états et vous constatez que
effectivement il y a cette grande
période autour de la Lune qui se termine
en 1975 76 avec la dernière sonde de
soviétique Luna vous constatez aussi
qu'il y a effectivement comme à cette
époque deux acteurs les États-Unis et
l'Union soviétique et vous remarquez
aussi le nombre d'échecs c'est à dire
que ce que je tiens à souligner c'est
que c'est une époque du spatial ou d'une
certaine façon l'échec est admis l'échec
fait partie du développement de
l'activité spatiale et ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on pourrait entendre
aujourd'hui c'est assez intéressant par
des anciens de l'activité spatiale qui
disent on a peur de l'échec aujourd'hui
et on le voit bien par exemple avec le
lanceur SLS qui décolle pas et bon et je
comprends qu'on veuille pas le faire
exposer sur le pas de tir mais
à peu de hauteur mais en réalité il y a
v cette espèce de culture du risque on
voit bien que ça diminue et donc du coup
le nombre de missions diminues parce que
effectivement ça coûte plus cher et puis
parce qu'il y a ce désintérêt pour la
lune l'émission que vous voyez en 90 qui
sont d'ailleurs des échecs et puis
ensuite autour des années 2005-2010 ce
sont les nouveaux acteurs c'est-à-dire
l'arrivée du Japon alors il a déjà
essayé puis il a échoué les Européens en
arrivent juste avant avec Smart mais
vous voyez les Japonais les Chinois et
les Indiens nouvelles puissances
spatiales de l'exploration qui arrive
dans ces années là et puis aujourd'hui à
partir de
2019-2020 et maintenant jusqu'à cet
horizon de 2024 2025 on va avoir une
multiplication des missions lunaires
avec la Corée du Sud l'Inde la Chine les
États-Unis la Russie on va voir l'Europe
bien évidemment en coopération et sur
Mars que je vais pas commenter parce que
c'est pas le sujet du jour vous voyez
que c'est un petit peu le même schéma
avec sur Mars cette cet effet qu'on
trouve aussi un peu sur la lune qui est
que finalement vous avez parmi les Rover
martiens de nationalités les Rover
américain et un Rover chinois j'insiste
parce que on n'est pas à parité mais
effectivement le hasard
malheureux font que la sonde européenne
qui partait avec les Russes Mars Express
n'a pas pu n'a pas pu décoller à cause
du covid et que bon bah maintenant la
mission est malheureusement enterrée
contenue de des circonstances géoptiques
je veux la diapositive suivante donc les
USA l'exploration c'est ce que vous
évoquiez en fait il y a deux mots clés
qui se retrouvent derrière ce projet
américain c'est le leadership je
rappelle que la NASA a quand même été
créée avec parmi ces missions la mission
de montrer au monde qui était leader
dans ce nouveau milieu qui était
l'espace en réponse à tout le discours
qu'on a un peu oublié aujourd'hui
mais qui était le discours de l'Union
soviétique sur l'homme nouveau qui était
un homme nouveau socialiste car seul le
marxisme par la science et la
technologie permettait l'ouverture et
j'insiste je fais ce petit rappel parce
que ce n'est plus quelque chose qu'on
entend du tout dans le discours chinois
c'est-à-dire que quand on a tendance à
transposer le parallèle guerre froide
concurrence États-Unis Union soviétique
et aujourd'hui guerre plus plus jaune en
dirham entre la les États-Unis et la
Chine on n'est pas du tout dans le même
dans le même recul et dans la même idée
la Chine c'est qu'elle est en retard par
rapport aux États-Unis ça je pense que
c'est quand même extrêmement important
et en même temps on voit cette vision
absolument cruciale dans le programme
américain mais ça remonte au milieu des
années 80 de la nécessité de la
commercialisation et de la nécessité
d'investir pour permettre à des acteurs
privés de trouver leur place et de faire
leur business Elon Musk est
véritablement alors c'était pas Elon
Musk que la NASA attendait elle savait
pas qu'elle mais il y avait
véritablement avec programme code entre
autres un soutien très fort pour donner
aux entrepreneurs privés l'envie de
commencer à agir dans l'espace et ça
c'est une dimension qui n'existe qu'aux
États-Unis je peux vous assurer
qu'existe pas du tout en Chine même
aujourd'hui et qu'elle évidemment jamais
existé sous cette forme en Europe et
donc on voit effectivement aujourd'hui
Elon Musk en sous-traitant de la NASA
pour assurer les transports en orbite
basse mais aussi vers la lune est-ce que
ce sera Elon Musk et seulement Elon Musk
ça c'est une autre histoire et la
mission qui reste à la NASA avec son
gros lanceur SLS c'est vraiment elle
d'ouvrir l'avenir bon moi
personnellement ça on pourrait avoir un
débat féministe c'est-à-dire assez
étonnant que pour une fois en soi quatre
femmes et un homme vous voyez ce que ça
fait d'être en minorité Alban mais dans
la salle en revanche c'est un peu plus
un peu plus classique et ça correspond
pour des rations je fais essentielle ma
carrière en étant souvent la seule la
seule à à la tribune quand il y avait
des interventions de ce type mais
effectivement cette idée que la grande
une des grandes innovations du programme
Artemis c'est de faire atterrir la
première femme et la première personne
de couleur bon
on a un polémiquement correct sur lequel
on pourrait on pourrait débattre
j'imagine qu'il y a quand même d'autres
enjeux en tout cas c'est extrait du site
de la NASA je veux bien là et ça passe
vous avez vu avant le commercial même si
vous n'avez pas vu alors les grilles de
lecture alors ça je pense que c'est
quelque chose sur lequel on reviendra
beaucoup aux questions et je veux pas
prendre trop de temps dans mon exposé
introductif mais je pense qu'il faut
découpler ce que sont les ambitions
chinoises en tant que tel est-ce que
sont la perception des ambitions
chinoises par les Occidentaux et les
Américains en particulier dans le
contexte global des relations terrestres
entre la Chine et les États-Unis la
Chine effectivement aujourd'hui que ce
soit sur Mars que ce soit sur la lune
adapte décline le slogan d'oxygin depuis
le début de son mandat qui est le rêve
chinois et effectivement le spatial et
le rêve c'est quelque chose qui va
particulièrement bien ensemble donc on a
cette idée que à l'horizon 2049 la Chine
devra avoir atteint un niveau qui est
celui des premières puissances ils
disent pas l'avoir dépassé les
États-Unis quand même dans le discours
officiel mais dites juste qui doivent
être arrivés à parité et d'ici là
effectivement bien la Chine dans son
programme spatial et on le voit car tous
les 5 ans la Chine sort depuis 2000 un
livre blanc où elle décline ses
activités des cinq dernières années et
ses activités des cinq futures années
puisque elle a un programme quinquennal
et donc on voit bien que son objectif
est simple c'est cocher toutes les cases
de tout ce que les autres puissances
spatiales plus anciennes qu'elles ont
réussi à faire et donc forcément on a
qu'un seul satellite naturel et c'est la
lune et donc aujourd'hui ce que fait la
Chine quand elle fait ses retours
d'échantillons et bien c'est ce que
l'Union so petit café en 1971 quand elle
a fait ses retours d'échantillons sauf
que évidemment le spatial a évolué on
fait pas ça de la même façon que vous
imaginez bien que en termes de
télé-activité ramener quelques centaines
de grammes à l'époque c'était pas du
tout la même chose que aujourd'hui avec
les nouveaux moyens à la fois
informatique électronique d'intelligence
artificielle etc ramener des
échantillons la carte à côté que j'ai
prise c'est une carte donc que j'ai cité
qui sortent de bloomberg.com où il y a
un des multiples articles sur cette
rivalité entre la Chine et les
États-Unis et donc vous voyez c'est ça
qui me qui m'amuse beaucoup que on a
choisi de montrer les sites
d'actes d'activités
posées sur la Lune par les Américains et
les Chinois donc on voit bien que les
chinois sont seuls sur la face cachée le
petit rond à droite que il y a quand
même bon les missions Apollo qui sont de
nombreuses que la mission champ de 3
mais ça ça va changer parce que la Chine
va accumuler les missions et c'est
normal puisqu'elle est en phase
d'apprentissage et on voit plus aucune
autre mission par exemple l'émission
russe qui ont totalement disparu donc on
a une construction du discours de cette
opposition chez des États-Unis sur
lequel moi j'insiste beaucoup parce que
je pense qu'il y a un vrai effet
boomerang je rappellerai une anecdote
alors elle est ancienne elle date de
Obama mais quand Obama avait décidé de
ne pas suivre le programme lunaire qui
avait été évoqué par bouche junior moi
j'étais en Chine à ce moment-là et les
collègues chinois étaient vraiment
dépités en disant Obama a fait ça pour
tuer le programme lunaire chinois et moi
j'étais extrêmement surprise et je
voyais pas du tout la logique et donc je
comprends pas et ils m'ont dit bah si au
Balma a dit que revenir sur la lune
c'est quelque chose qui a été fait il y
a 50 ans que ça a plus aucun intérêt et
que c'est complètement has been nous
comment on va faire pour vendre notre
programme
spatiale lunaire à nos dirigeants et ça
c'est une question permanente bon
heureusement Trump est arrivé donc 2024
2025 et tout ce discours américain qui
est de dire la Chine va nous rattraper
la Chine est à notre housse je sais pas
du tout qu'il est faux bon la Chine est
à leur trousse et encore de la marche
mais c'est vrai que la Chine est en
train d'essayer de rattraper c'est
totalement évident mais il faut pas non
plus grossir le trait au moins que les
journaux chinois se contentent de citer
le New York Times en disant les
Américains disent qu'on est en train de
devenir les premiers compétiteurs et
qu'on va les rattraper et je pense que
nous européens il faut vraiment
puisqu'on a quand même ce recul par
rapport à cette à cette partage du monde
il faut qu'on montre qu'on a notre place
et qu'il y a pas seulement une rivalité
Chine États-Unis construite par les
États-Unis et qui sert la propagande
chinoise de toute façon inévitablement
ceci dit bon je pousse le train un peu
loin pour assister et à les contre la
l'opinion facilement reprise sans qu'on
est toujours
société analysé au fond je ne dis pas le
contraire la Chine ambitionne bien
d'être une très grande puissance
spatiale je suis bien d'accord là-dessus
donc je veux bien la planche suivante
donc quels sont les autres acteurs parce
que c'est finalement la question qui se
pose pour tous les enjeux que vous
évoquiez et que les autres participants
à cette table vont décliner alors on a
quand même en Europe des ambitions on
l'a vu à travers l'étude de la NRT et
Clarisse Alban vont le vont le
re-développer on a des ambitions
européennes la question c'est comment
va-t-on les confirmer qu'elle va être le
programme PHARE qu'on va réussir
peut-être à faire émerger sachant que
derrière dans le spatial et sur la lune
peut-être plus encore qu'ailleurs il y a
cette question de l'adhésion du public
et et là il faut peut-être pas se
tromper sur les thèmes qu'on va mettre
en avant alors est-ce bien évidemment
l'indépendance européenne est un thème
naturel
l'image de l'Europe est également un
thème évident dans le domaine
technologies ça va être plus compliqué à
élaborer comme discours à la fois sur la
compétitivité et sur la question de la
militarisation dont on pourrait reparler
dans la mesure où ces enjeux sont là
encore assez assez compliqué l'émission
Au japonaise il y en a mais elles sont
directement associées vraiment très
fortement intégrés dans le programme
Artemis américain on a la question de la
confirmation de l'effacement de la
Russie parce que quand même la situation
actuelle fait que déjà le programme
spatial
russe était mal financé donc on peut se
douter qui va être encore plus mal
financé en même temps pour la Russie
disparaître de la scène spatiale c'est
pas acceptable puisque c'est un des
grands héritages avec le nucléaire de
l'Union soviétique il y a cet accord
avec les Chinois d'une station j'y
insiste de recherche ça c'est très
intéressant parce que les Chinois
assistent beaucoup sur le fait qu'à la
différence des Américains qui parlent de
commercialisation et qui parle d'une
exploitation commerciale de la lune il
faudra bien exploiter aussi sur la lune
pour les chinois mais eux parle d'une
base de recherche donc ça serait cette
mission Luna 25 qui représenterait un
élément à l'âge je crois plus de 10 ans
de retard quand même et puis là où on en
vient à une autre aspect intéressante et
des ambiguïtés pour un nouvel acteur
comme l'Inde qui lui aujourd'hui est
pris parce qu'il a un petit budget l'un
budget de 1 milliard de dollars là où
les États-Unis on tourne à 50 milliards
de dollars donc on parle pas du tout de
la même chose et nous en Europe on est
autour de 13 14 milliards à peu près
l'équivalent des Chinois et bien là
ambiguïté de la politique spatiale
indienne qui avait trois missions vers
la lune chambre Ryan et qui aujourd'hui
retarde un peu sa mission chandry 3
parce que elle met plus d'argent sur sa
mission habitée sa première mission d'un
indien qui volerait dans l'espace et on
voit bien cette dichotomie finalement
entre le spatial habité et l'exploration
de la lune qui se ferait quand même
essentiellement avec des robots et les
ambitions de la Corée du Sud qui elle va
voler avec cette space mais qui veut
être présente en 2022 plus effectivement
savoir ce que vont devenir les nouveaux
explorateurs qui sont aussi des
financiers et là je parle on y reviendra
sûrement des Émirats arabes unis et bon
le Luxembourg lui est intégré dans les
arts mais les Émirats arabes unis qui
ont une coopération très ouverte
aujourd'hui avec les États-Unis et le
Japon ça c'est déjà fait mais aussi avec
la Chine puisqu'ils ont signé en
septembre de cette année un accord avec
la Chine pour voler à bord d'une mission
7 en 2026 et puis dernier point parce
que ça me paraît très intéressant c'est
pas tout à fait un hasard si le
Luxembourg et les Émirats arabes unis
sont un petit peu les fers de lance en
matière de
réglementation des ressources
là il y a eu à Esch cette compétition
donc au Luxembourg avec les A et le
centre des innovations en matière des
ressources spatiales qui est
luxembourgeois sur les le petit robot
qui pourrait forer la lune et il y a en
même temps à Esch une grande exposition
qui s'appelle des terres rouges au terre
martienne le luxembourge le
Luxembourgeois insistant beaucoup et ça
j'avais pas réalisé à quel point c'était
fort dans leur imaginaire sur le fait
que leur richesse est d'abord construite
sur la ressources minières et nous on
les voit toujours en ressources enfin on
les voit en puissance financière et
économique et on les voit investir et
tenir ce discours sur les
sociétés qui vont pouvoir exploiter les
ressources de ce point de vue financier
mais il y a aussi quand même cette
arrière plan des ressources minières je
veux bien la diapositive suivante et
j'ai presque fini
les modes d'exploitation des ressources
ça c'est le choix essentiel bon est-ce
que on va exploiter des ressources pour
les ramener sur la terre ça c'est quand
même peu probable donc effectivement les
questions c'est si vous faites un
habitat lunaire et même une base
semi-automatique ben effectivement il va
falloir essayer de récupérer le maximum
de ressources in situ parce que vous
allez pas tout monter de la terre c'est
évident pour les astéroïdes là c'est
différent forêt les astéroïdes et
exploiter les ressources des astéroïdes
ça ça pourrait peut-être être plus vu
comme éventuellement ramener sur terre
mais c'est quand même tout un débat la
question de la vocation commerciale que
vous évoquiez est-ce que il y a un
marché où sont les acheteurs où sont les
producteurs quels sont l'organisation de
ces flux entre ces localisations et ça
montant que je grave sont des sujets que
je ne traite pas mais qui me paraissent
particulièrement important cette
question cette idée d'une économie
orbitale qu'est-ce qu'elle recouvre je
crois que là puisque vous faites de la
prospective vraiment le sujet de
l'économie orbitale c'est certainement
un des très beau sujet à traiter et puis
dans le cas des acteurs quelle est la
part de la puissance publique par
rapport aux acteurs privés ce que nous
savons tous que ces acteurs privés aux
États-Unis sont partis sur la base de
financement public et c'est absolument
pas de l'argent c'est pas seulement leur
argent c'est aussi leur argent mais pas
seulement leur argent enfin la question
des utilisateurs non autonomes dont
d'une certaine façon l'Europe fait
partie aujourd'hui puisque nous n'avons
pas fait le choix de faire voler
nous-mêmes et revenir sur Terre nos
propres astronautes voilà plus une
vocation spéculative je pense que ma
dernière planche arrive voilà les enjeux
de demain donc la question de la
rentabilité quel serait les
bénéficiaires et ce le point important
effectivement c'est celui que vous avez
ouvert c'est à dire la question de
l'innovation qui est derrière et la
question des nouveaux développements et
des nouveaux services c'est certain
est-ce que on a un modèle économique
unique qui est celui des États-Unis ça
me paraît pas évident la Chine a un
autre type de modèle économique et de la
même façon à laisser de développer de
nouvelles sociétés mais qui sont des
émanations de ces grandes entreprises
d'État donc on voit bien qu'il y a la
volonté de changer l'écosystème
industriel mais véritablement quand même
toujours sous l'égide de l'État ou des
fonds qui sont en partie défend
d'origine étatique on a une question qui
me paraît très importante aujourd'hui il
se trouve que le spatial revient à la
mode et je fais pas mal de de
conférences dans des et j'ai des études
aussi qui est vraiment un sujet qu'on
revoit et qu'on avait vu dans les études
de la NRT cette question de la
durabilité cette question du coup
carbone et cette question du devenir
après la fin de l'exploitation on voit
bien tous les reliquats que les
exploitations industrielles peuvent
poser sur terre comment ça va se passer
sur la lune sachant qu'accessoirement
les astronomes sont modérément
enthousiastes à l'idée d'avoir de la
poussière qui flotte autour de la Lune
s'il va l'utiliser la face cachée pour
une observatoire etc etc donc il y a
quand même beaucoup de sujet qui sont
des sujets très importants et il me
semble parce que nous les Européens nous
arrivons un peu après nous sommes en
train de forger notre réflexion on le
voit bien on est au groupe prospective
donc je pense que là c'est très
important qu'on les intègre et qu'on est
un discours clair sur sur le sujet les
industriels commencent à le penser la
loi sur les opérations spatiales du CNES
est une loi importante mais où est-ce
qu'on va dans cette direction et là
aussi est-ce qu'on se singularise dans
cette direction ce qui me paraîtrait une
option on retrouve les préoccupations de
protection planétaire qui préoccupe
aussi beaucoup à la fois les astronomes
et les scientifiques mais aussi le
public et donc on en arrive à un point
qui me paraît particulièrement sensible
aujourd'hui qui est la relation entre la
puissance publique les médias et les
opinions publiques puisque aujourd'hui
on a un discours des médias sur le
spatial qui est très souvent un discours
décalqué du discours anglo-saxon
et qui n'est pas toujours très informé
donc le rôle des médias sur ces sujets
là est extrêmement important et il me
semble que ça serait également un point
sur lequel il faudrait s'attacher voilà
j'ai peut-être été un peu long mais j'ai
dressé le tableau général merci de votre
attention merci beaucoup je vais
maintenant passer la parole à Madame
ultra Guérard
merci beaucoup bonjour à tous
alors aujourd'hui donc on va parler des
ressources lunaires alors déjà peut-être
qu'est-ce qu'on entend par les
ressources ici en fait on va se
focaliser sur les éléments du tableau
périodique de Mendeleïev c'est à dire
les atomes et les molécules qui en
dérivent par exemple l'eau l'hydrogène
l'oxygène les minéraux ce genre de ce
genre de ressources alors tout d'abord
je voudrais insister sur un point c'est
qu'il y a déjà un enjeu de connaissant
de ces ressources spatiales en
particulier ce notamment sur la lune qui
est pourtant effectivement un corps qui
est assez proche de nous c'est souvent
des connaissances qu'on peut avoir qu'on
a acquis par des observations à distance
donc à travers de la spectrométrie par
exemple donc c'est des approches qui
sont quand même relativement
macroscopiques qui couvre la surface et
non pas ce qu'il y a en dessous ou alors
à travers des observations in situ mais
alors à ce moment là elles sont assez
local et là aussi elle reste cantonnée à
la à l'approche surface en tout cas de
de la lune alors on a eu des missions
robotiques ou habitées in situ qui ont
permis effectivement de faire cette
cette prospection de surface ça a été
montré par Isabelle dans son diagramme
s'agissant de la lune on a assez peu
finalement de points
d'observation on a parcouru au mieux
quelques dizaines de kilomètres sur la
surface de la Lune et donc la
connaissance qu'on peut en avoir est
quand même très très partiel
on a aussi donc la possibilité de faire
des retours d'échantillons ça a été fait
donc bien sûr dans le cadre des missions
Apollo où on a ramené quelques quelques
centaines de kilos de roches lunaires
on le fait également sur des astéroïdes
que ça a été le cas par exemple sur sur
Riu avec la mission Hayabusa ou avec
l'astéroïde ben nous avec la Hayabusa la
mission japonaise et de même avec
l'astéroïde ben nous avec la mission
Osiris Rex de des États-Unis mais là on
est on parle de quelques grammes de
récolter voir quelques centaines de
grammes s'agissant d'Osiris Rex
puisqu'on on a quelques quelques
incertitudes sur ce qui a été
effectivement ce qui pourrait être amené
et puis plus tard on parle aussi de
retour d'échantillons de Mars mais là
c'est dans un futur plus plus lointain à
l'horizon 2030
ce sont des missions qui coûtent
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
voire plusieurs milliards d'euros donc
vous voyez j'ai parlé de au mieux
quelques centaines de kilos pour
l'émission Apollo plusieurs grammes ou
dizaines de grammes pour d'autres
missions donc au jour d'aujourd'hui le
coût de rapporter des échantillons de
matière extraterrestres sur sur terre et
très largement prohibitif et donc on
comprend que ce n'est pas demain qu'on
fera un usage terrestre de ses
ressources même le Luxembourg qui est un
pays très en pointe sur ces sujets là ce
projet sur ce type de d'éventuellement
de retour de de matière extraterrestre
sur Terre ce projet à 20 ans et au-delà
alors quel usage du coup de ses
ressources bien on va plutôt se
focaliser effectivement sur
l'utilisation in situ de ces ressources
ce qu'on appelle distrus à la fois pour
du support vie en cas de vol habité donc
pour fournir de l'oxygène de l'eau un
support vie des astronautes des futurs
missions artemises par exemple ou des
éléments de construction que ce soit
donc des métaux des minéraux en
utilisant notamment le récolite ou les
ou les roches pour construire quoi bien
des habitats des infrastructures ou
encore un outil d'utilisation pour
produire du carburant puisque comme vous
l'avez mentionné tout à l'heure la Lune
est vue comme un tremplin d'une certaine
façon pour aller explorer des corps plus
lointains comme mars bien sûr et donc la
possibilité de produire et de décoller
de la lune pour aller produire des
ressources
de carburant pour décoller de la lune
pour aller vers vers Mars par exemple
est une quelque chose qui est également
alors il y a des enjeux de connaissances
mais il y a également des enjeux
technologiques puisque là on parle donc
de faire des forages de conditionner ces
matériaux de les stocker de les usiner
avec toutes les contraintes qui peuvent
être liées à l'environnement spatial
donc là sur ces utilisations Institut
des ressources on est plutôt un horizon
de 10 ans
dans le dans ce dans les prospectives où
les perspectives que nous pouvons avoir
alors quelles sont les activités en
cours et à venir et bien il y a tout
d'abord donc un travail important de
prospection de ces ressources au niveau
européen les a avaient un projet qui
s'appelle prospect qui devait voler sur
Luna 27 donc avec les Russes donc voilà
je pense qu'il va falloir trouver un
autre véhicule de pour héberger ce type
de mission alors il s'agissait en fait
d'un forage et d'un laboratoire
d'analyses in situ notamment pour voir
étudier la présence d'eau sur dans le
sous-sol martien
nous avons également donc des
expérimentations en conditions réelles
qui ont pu être menées par exemple à
l'expérimentation Moxie qui a consiste à
produire de l'oxygène à partir du CO2 de
l'atmosphère de Mars c'est un c'est une
expérience de la NASA qui pardon du
gibier et du MIT qui est en embarqué sur
le la mission de la NASA persévérance
donc qui a produit en avril 2021 5G
d'oxygène donc ce qui correspond à peu
près à 10 minutes de respiration pour un
astronaute donc ça consiste en fait à
aspirer compresser chauffer puis cliver
le CO2 de l'atmosphère de Mars pour
produire de l'oxygène et du monoxyde de
carbone alors c'est extrêmement
consommateur en énergie quand on met en
route cette expérimentation les autres
expérimentation sont arrêtées
nous avons également d'autres d'autres
approches qui consistent par exemple à
faire des simulations du régolite de la
lune alors ce sont des expérimentations
qui sont réalisées par exemple par
l'Agence spatiale européenne dans le cas
de yopen astronaute Center qui donc à
partir de roche souvent basaltique
consiste à simuler le régolite il y a
également un consortium français avec
les Mines d'Albi rap et l'ONERA qui
cherche à faire la même chose en
Auvergne en utilisant les roches
volcaniques de des volcans d'Auvergne
et donc là c'est c'est donc l'objectif
de voir ce qu'on peut faire avec ce
regolithe dont on sait qu'il n'est pas
lunaire qui n'est pas une substance très
très sympathique c'est très abrasif
c'est ça pose beaucoup de difficultés
pour ne serait-ce que pour le
l'environnement des astronautes les
combinaisons etc mais aussi après que
peut faire que peut-on faire de ce
matériau telle est la question
il y a également donc le l'international
space exploration coordination Group qui
a produit un rapport en 2021 qui
s'appelle lise rue donc in situations
gap assessment TriPort qui vise donc à
faire l'inventaire de tout ce qu'il
faudrait pouvoir être capable de faire
et comment le et quelles sont les
problématiques d'innovation de
connaissances et d'innovation qui sont
associées à ses besoins
voilà pour ce qui est donc des activités
je dirais des missions et des recherches
en cours
alors évidemment derrière ça il y a
également tout un cadre juridique qui
n'est pas et qui évidemment est
important à considérer puisqu'il s'agit
de mener ses activités dans le respect
des traités existants surtout le traité
de l'espace de 1977 qui propose
notamment le principe de notre
non-appropriation par un État ou un
privé de corps de corps céleste
extraterrestre donc si on fait un petit
focus sur sur les aspects juridiques bon
je vais rester quand même assez générale
si vous avez des questions plus précises
ma collègue qui est une expert en droit
spatiale qui pourrait éventuellement
vous répondre alors sur si on passe si
on parle des aspects juridiques il y a
un certain nombre de pays qui se sont
dotés de loi nationale s'agissant donc
de l'exploitation des ressources
extraterrestres c'est le cas des
États-Unis avec un exotisme exécutive
order en 2020 le Luxembourg qui
finalement a été précurseur sur ces
sujets là en 2017 et les Émirats arabes
unis qui ont également mis en place une
loi en 2020
et donc c'est ces lois vise à autoriser
l'exploitation des ressources spatiales
et leur appropriation dans le cadre de
donc d'une utilisation
dans le cadre des ressources
extraterrestres alors s'agissant de la
loi relative aux opérations spatiales de
la France qui a été mise en place en
2008 et qui vise à couvrir enfin à
protéger les biens et les personnes dans
le cas de l'exploiter afin de
l'utilisation de l'espace de l'accès et
de l'utilisation de l'espace ne couvre
pas ces aspects de d'exploitation des
ressources et donc c'est un sujet qui
est à l'étude actuellement puisqu'il est
il est une révision de cette loi est en
cours pour prendre en compte toutes les
évolutions récentes de de des activités
spatiales qui ont beaucoup beaucoup
évolué ces derniers temps et donc cet
aspect là devra être également pris en
compte dans la loi la loi française
alors il y a aussi le cadre multilatéral
et donc ce sont les fameuses accords
Artemis qui ont été proposés par les
États-Unis à leur partenaire
internationaux que la France a signé en
juin cette année qui a une section donc
qui entièrement dédiée à cette à cette
problématique de l'exploitation des
ressources qui met en avant le bénéfice
pour pour l'humanité pour le support aux
opérations
insistent sur la nécessaire cohérence
avec le traité de 1967 le besoin
d'informer les Nations Unies sur les
activités relatives à ces exploitation
et insiste aussi beaucoup sur les
efforts multilatéraux qui sont
nécessaires pour pour travailler sur ces
sujets là
voilà donc la France a signé ces accords
Artemis considérant que ces accords
n'étaient pas en opposition avec le
traité de
l'utilisation de l'espace de 1967 que la
France a signé erratifié
[Musique]
alors tout en la France assigné ces
accords Artemis tout en insistant
beaucoup sur le besoin de continuer les
travaux dans un cadre mutilatral plus
ouvert plus large au sein du copyos et
notamment la France a poussé pour la
création d'un groupe de travail qui
couvre les activités d'exploration
d'exploitation et d'utilisation des
ressources spatiales ça a été ça a été
fait la décision de la création de ce
groupe a été prise lors de la 60e
réunion du sous Comité juridique du
copuos donc le ce groupe a vu son mandat
et ses attributions définies donc il
s'agit de à la fois de l'échange
d'informations de définir des activités
de d'identifier les activités de R&T et
d'innovation qui sont qui sont
nécessaires cela couvre évidemment aussi
les aspects juridiques en particulier
donc par rapport au traité existants
également ça pose également la question
des avantages de nouveaux instruments de
gouvernance
aussi si besoin était des ensembles ça
évoque la possibilité d'avoir d'un
ensemble de principes de base qui
pourraient déboucher sur une résolution
des Nations Unies et un certain nombre
de points qui qui seraient à approfondir
donc voilà ces travaux sont en cours
c'est vrai que le processus onunisien
est un processus qui est assez assez
long mais qui quelque part est
nécessaire puisque le avantage de
d'embarquer toutes les toutes les
grandes puissances spatiales
ce qui évidemment est essentiel dans ce
cadre là
alors autre point important qui a été
évoqué par Isabelle notamment vers la
fin de sa présentation c'est évidemment
la stimulation du secteur privé
alors évidemment côté côté américain il
y a énormément d'initiatives qui qui ont
été prises qui sont en cours
des challenges des prix des stimuler ces
activités privées
autour et éventuellement sur la lune
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle aussi le
programme clips pour commercial du Nord
pelote services qui a été mis en place
en 2019
donc voilà une forte activité aux
États-Unis mais effectivement des
acteurs privés qui agissent beaucoup
quand même pour pour le compte de la
puissance publique et sur des
financements qui sont en grande partie
des financements publics
côté agence spatiale européenne dans le
programme enveloppe de d'exploration il
y a de plus en plus d'activités qui
visent également à favoriser
la prise de d'initiative d'acteurs
commerciaux mais ça reste quand même
assez émergent
côté français bien il y a donc eu
l'initiative de la NRT Objectif Lune
dont on parlerons mes collègues Clarisse
et Alban côté CNES le CNES c'était
associé à l'incubateur Nubo pour
promouvoir donc à travers Tex the moon
pour donner la possibilité à des
startups de bénéficier d'un programme
d'incubation donc il y a au jour
d'aujourd'hui 8 startups qui qui ont été
sélectionnés et qui qui bénéficient ou
qui vont bénéficier de ce soutien pour
pour l'innovation
a également des activités de prospective
à travers spacibles donc là c'est
vraiment le volet plus plus prospectif
et nous travaillons au sein du CNES à
une feuille de route technologique qui
recouvre alors pas seulement l'aspect
ressource ressources spatiales mais
également tout ce qui est vol habité
support vie aux astronautes
la question se nourrit respirer boire
dans l'espace en font partie bien sûr
donc c'est ce sont des choses qui qui
sont à l'étude actuellement
alors comme vous le voyez donc ce sont
des activités qui restent en tout cas
aux côtés européens relativement
préliminaires mais on voit bien qu'il y
a au niveau des agences spatiales
au niveau européen et en particulier au
CNES une volonté de s'impliquer de plus
en plus dans ces dans ces activités et
effectivement je pense qu'il y a un lien
sur laquelle lequel nous devons être
attentifs et ça a été très bien dit par
Isabelle c'est les aspects aussi
durabilités de ces activités il me
semble que effectivement la France a
toujours finalement été assez exemplaire
dans ses activités spatiales et
notamment en se dotant très très vite
finalement d'une loi relative aux
opérations spatiales donc je pense que
ça doit rester aussi notre un peu notre
marque de fabrique si je puis dire de
faire attention à la durabilité des
activités et à la protection des biens
et des personnes
merci merci beaucoup j'ai passé
maintenant à la parole madame Clarisse
en gelier
les sénateurs merci beaucoup de votre
invitation et aussi merci de votre
discours introductible de vos discours
introductifs parce que vous osez des
mots comme souveraineté militarisation
géopolitique
commercialisation et c'est assez nouveau
et je parle au nom des membres de la NRT
qu'on participait aux travaux qu'on mène
sous la présidence de claudi ignoré et
aussi partiellement du cneche du
partiellement ça pas toujours été le le
cas mais
on on a eu du mal à parler de ça de
manière très libérée et on était
beaucoup plus sur la question bien tenue
de l'exploration plutôt que d'ouvrir des
chantiers sur des problématiques et vous
le voyez un peu dans le blanc où on
affirme vraiment les questions de
dimension militaires géopolitique
conflits etc et ça je vraiment je vous
remercie d'oser en parler parce que
c'est un véritable sujet et de
découpiller les tabous pour pouvoir
exposer des battre et décider en votre
cénacle ensuite mais me paraît
extrêmement précieux donc vraiment merci
je parle aussi au nom des membres de NRT
dont je rappelle l'intersectorialité ça
couvre tous les secteurs d'activités
publiques et privés et surtout toutes
les disciplines scientifiques alors moi
mes messages je vais essayer d'être
assez rapide mais mes messages d'abord
c'est que il faut qu'on ait conscience
qu'il s'agit d'une approche européenne
on sait pas la France c'est pas
l'allemagne-sol c'est pas les Pays-Bas
c'est vraiment une question qui se veut
au niveau européen et la France est un
acteur historique du spatial donc elle a
son mot à dire mais c'est vraiment en ce
sens c'était au niveau européen que nous
pourrons discuter avec les États-Unis
d'une part les chinois dont on a rappelé
les les résultats sur la ligne l'état du
niveau spatial sur la ligne du temps
mais qui ont bien décidé de s'emparer de
la maison lune et donc si nous européens
nous voulons pouvoir compter dans la
gouvernance de ce terrain lunaire qui
n'est pas une option c'est sauf si
l'humanité disparaît à l'horizon 2100 on
ira sur la lune l'humain ira sur la lune
donc là on n'est pas dans le
questionnement si on va y aller on est
dans le questionnement si l'Europe doit
participer ou non à cette aventure sur
l'hôtel effectivement du bien commun des
dimensions humanistes des valeurs de
durabilité de la protection de la maison
terre avant tout parce que ce berceau
qui qui duquel on sort enfin a priori on
va pas le détruire au bénéfice de
quelques happy fous qui iraient sur la
lune mais si on veut compter il faut
être dans le Sénacle de la gouvernance
donc en être et pour en être il y a en
fait qu'un vrai levier c'est le levier
scientifique qui était et technologique
si on rien à porter d'autre que notre
que nos beaux propos ça suffira pas donc
ça veut dire qu'il y a un enjeu de
compétences technologique et les
entreprises du spatial historique sont
prêtes à en jouer mais les non spatiales
aussi c'est à dire que moi j'ai vu au
travers de l'organisation du Gala lune
qui a été autant financée et ça je le
dis grâce aux acteurs du non spatial il
y a eu aussi il y a un groupe était là
le CNES était là mais il y avait eu il y
a eu des gens de l'automobile il y a eu
des gens de la construction bâtimentaire
il y a eu des gens de la communication
donc on voit bien que l'homme s'est
emparé des orbites basses terrestres
mais avOcatiOn à s'emparer des orbites
lunaires et on a milité pour une
constellation européenne de
communication autour de la Lune et on
milite pour que nos entreprises privées
du spatial et d'union spatiale ensemble
appuie la dimension française et
européenne pour constituer un objectif
stratégique
qui se décline au niveau militaire
scientifique technologique d'exploration
peut-être d'exploitation mais permettent
à la maison Europe dans notre alors je
vais m'arrêter une seconde sur la Space
scientifique comme vous l'avez dit
Pascal on a encore beaucoup à apprendre
donc on voit bien que la maison en
Europe a déjà dans sa justification d'y
aller des connaissances scientifiques
sur lesquelles elle a toujours misé et
elle elle serait ce serait bien dommage
qu'elle s'en est parti
alors que on a encore à apprendre de
l'exploration spatiale notamment à
partir d'une face cachée où on peut
installer des appareils bien ancrés sur
un sol entre guillemets fixe qui est
moins le cas sur les observateurs qui
sont sur des sur des sondes et qui
bougent ou qui sont sur des orbites d'un
autre ordre on a avoir aussi la
physiologie et la psychologie de
l'humain dans l'espace alors ça c'est
une dimension qu'il faut encore
approcher on sait qu'il va s'arrêter
donc évidemment notre petit satellite
qui est quand même somme toute tout à
fait prête chez nous est un bon un bon
laboratoire et ça ce sont des dimensions
scientifico technologiques qu'il faut
qu'on cultive enfin de notre point de
vue et les entreprises et ça j'insiste
ont mis ça dans leur feuille de route
alors elle le disent ou elle le dit pas
mais quasiment toutes les entreprises du
CAC qui ont pensé alors elles vont le
décliner de manière affichée elles vont
participer comme certaines entreprises
de l'automobile à des programmes de la
NASA parce qu'elles ont été appelés ou
parce qu'elles ont décidé de le faire
elles y ont pensé en le disant un peu ou
on ne le disant pas moi j'ai des
entreprises que je réciterai pas qui
l'on met dans leur feuille de route mais
qui l'affiche pas parce que évidemment
qu'est-ce qu'on a derrière on a l'image
et c'est là où j'en viens à la dualité
un autre message que je souhaite porter
c'est quand on programme des recherches
R&D vers la lune et bien à la manière de
ce qu'on peut faire dans le milieu
militaire ayant le reflex
de programmer des choses duales
c'est-à-dire de financer des programmes
de recherche pour le spatial mais avec
un roi terrestre et on voit bien la
question vous êtes intervenus avec nous
sur les déserts en Festival
International de Géographie on voit bien
qu'on a des problèmes terrestres qui
renvoient quelque part à la capacité de
recyclage de vie dans des milieux
extrêmes et donc si d'impulsion on se
dit l'Europe il va pour porter une
parole aux valeurs humanistes je fais de
cours mais tout le monde a compris et de
durabilité parce qu'on va financer des
programmes à tendance dual je pense
qu'on a une équation qui peut parler à
nos concitoyens et c'est en ce sens que
que je voulais m'exprimer et puis je
finis sur les compétences là aussi on a
une histoire historique avec le spalcial
l'Europe fait partie des grandes
puissances conquérantes et c'est un mot
là aussi qui est pas très à la mode mais
enfin d'exploration d'autres territoires
je vais le dire comme ça et on a besoin
bonne compétences on sait et la NRT
porte aussi ce discours que les
entreprises françaises si on veut faire
des champions de demain à partir des
startups ou d'entreprises déjà
installées il va falloir davantage
renforcer les compères intenses en
scientifiques au sein des entreprises
que ce soit du niveau ingénieur mais
surtout du niveau de doctorat et là on a
des enjeux extrêmement intéressants qui
vont mobiliser les jeunes tous les
matins on entend dans les radios que les
jeunes volent que leur programme change
avec plus de durabilité plus
d'environnement mais mettons aussi du
spatial mais un spatial propre
effectivement
emmenons-les sur des territoires qui
font rêver dans cette dualité et donc je
termine sur ce besoin de compétences
merci de votre attention
merci à vous et pour conclure ces prises
de parole avant de laisser à nos
rapporteurs et puis à chacune à chacun
de nos collègues l'occasion de vous
poser des questions passer la parole
Alban Guillaume marche
donc je crois qu'il est déjà 9h30 donc
je vais essayer de faire court mais en
même temps que reste-t-il à dire après
les trois exposés qui précèdent
peut-être commencer devant cette
délégation sénatoriale à la prospective
par rappeler que quand on envoie des
objets dans l'espace on a peut-être pas
la même conception du temps que le
commun des mortels et que ce qu'on
appelle demain en dehors du Sénat ici
même ou ailleurs n'est pas le même
demain que quand on parle d'espace ce
qui fait que le premier élément que je
veux mettre en avant et je rejoins en
cela les trois positions précédentes
c'est que la question du retour sur la
lune n'en est plus une les Américains et
les Chinois vont y aller et demain et
demain au sens spatial c'est à dire
d'ici une grosse dizaine d'années mais
demain quand même
autre très structurelle à mettre en
avant de ces nouvelles ambitions
lunaires c'est qu'on a pour projet
d'installer une base en expansion
durable une base permanente et que donc
les besoins sont renouvelés à la fois en
énergie en support de vie mais également
en fait l'intégralité des besoins qu'on
avait par le passé des astronautes
plusieurs semaines sur la lune ça n'est
pas les faire survivre pendant quelques
jours il ne s'agit pas seulement de les
faire nourrir de s'assurer qu'ils aient
de l'oxygène pour quelques jours et
qu'ils puissent remonter après et
revenir de façon sécurisée l'enjeu à ce
stade c'est de les faire vivre le besoin
énergétique n'est pas le même le besoin
d'espace n'est pas le même en fait en
quelque sorte toutes les paramètres ou
presque changent s'agit donc non pas de
retourner sur la Lune et en cela
profitant d'être au Sénat français pour
donner tort au président Obama non oui
nous sommes déjà allés sur la lune de
cette façon là pas encore et donc il
faut réapprendre sans doute à retourner
sur l'île
l'autre très structurel et c'est celui
qui nous réunissent matin c'est que les
ressources sont en effet au cœur des
nouveaux programmes lunaires américains
et chinois les ressources sont au cœur
de ces programmes et donc ça n'est pas
un sujet de pure prospective
certes il reste encore des barrières
technologiques à surmonter pour pouvoir
exploiter ses ressources il faut encore
trouver des solutions des financements
une logique économique néanmoins
l'exploitation des ressources spatiales
n'est pas pour après-demain elle est
pour demain et ce demain est immédiat
à mon sens il faut distinguer deux types
d'exploitation des ressources spatiales
une qui relève de la prospective pure et
qui n'est pas à considérer dans
l'immédiat et une qui relève des enjeux
beaucoup plus concrets celles qui
relèvent du spatial de demain comme je
l'évoquais la première exploitation des
ressources et celle d'exploitation de
ressources spatiales à des fins
terrestres c'est à dire ponctionner des
ressources dans l'espace qui a ramené à
terre et s'en servir pour produire de
l'énergie pour la terre clairement comme
la notamment avancé Pascal ultra Gerard
ça n'est pas une exploitation des
ressources viables et à considérer dans
l'immédiat néanmoins une exploitation
des ressources spatiales pour l'espace
en particulier pour la production de
carburant c'est sur cet aspect là que je
vais me concentrer ce matin cette
exploitation des ressources là est tout
à fait à envisager est un enjeu immédiat
et sans doute celle qui est la plus
réaliste à considérer
l'exploitation des ressources spatiales
à des fins spatiales donc il se rue in
situations est une exploitation pour le
demain immédiat comme je l'ai dit et
juste à titre informatif la NASA a quand
même misé un milliard je le répète un
milliard de dollars c'est à dire à demi
budget spatial français
sur le développement de technologie
d'utilisation de ces ressources alors
bien évidemment vous me direz il y a des
défis technologiques à relever mais les
technologies impliquées pour cette
exploitation de ressources repose sur
des technologies déjà en cours de
développement ou développer pour la
terre notamment dans le cadre de la
transition énergétique et de l'hydrogène
veille revenir dans un instant alors ne
demandez pas au juriste que je suis de
vous construire des machines qui vont
exploiter ces ressources j'en suis tout
bonnement incapable néanmoins la NRT par
son groupe Objectif Lune a eu la chance
de compter des ingénieurs dans ses rangs
et vous pourrez retrouver à l'intérieur
de notre livre blanc justement ce mode
d'emploi partiel de l'exploitation des
ressources donc avec eux dans le Livre
blanc nous avons dessiné les contours de
ce que pourrait être ce modèle
d'exploitation des ressources lunaires
et en quelque sorte pour faire simple
sont pas extraire de la rigolites
lunaire chauffée dans un réacteur
catalyseur de l'oxygène les 10 réacteurs
catalyseurs devraient être
approvisionnent en énergie et ça n'est
pas un point à contourner mais néanmoins
on peut en effet extraire de la rigoler
de l'oxygène et sur le lunaire à
condition d'y arriver les premiers et
d'être sûr de pouvoir la récupérer de
cette eau lunaire par électrolyse on
peut récupérer de l'hydrogène et magie
magie si vous mettez de l'hydrogène et
de l'oxygène dans une fusée elle démarre
il s'agit donc de transformer la lune en
une sorte de station-service pour fuser
alors je sais que la métaphore n'est
peut-être pas bien venue vu l'actualité
récente mais si on arrive à en tout cas
à trouver un moyen de fabriquer du
carburant pour fuser à partir de la lune
il sera beaucoup plus simple de faire
taire l'une plus l'infini que de faire
taire plus l'infini donc globalement
l'enjeu à ce stade il est d'utiliser ses
ressources lunaires pour fabriquer du
carburant c'est une des exploitations
des ressources possibles comme l'a mis
en avant Pascal luttregera il existe
d'autres applications d'utilisation des
ressources spatiales notamment pour la
construction l'habitat et le support de
vie celle-ci qui se concentre sur le
carburant et c'est l'argument principal
qu'on contient dans le Livre blanc serre
la durabilité des missions spatiales
alors en effet il y a quelque chose de
paradoxal dans cette affirmation
exploitant des ressources au service de
la durabilité c'est sans doute un
message qui paraît
d'étonnant on va dire par rapport au
discours contient aujourd'hui sur
l'exploitation des ressources terrestres
et la sobriété qu'on doit avoir
vis-à-vis de ces dernières pour réussir
à respecter nos engagements climatiques
néanmoins nous croyons à la NRT Objectif
Lune que cette exploitation des
ressources spatiales sert la durabilité
pour au moins trois raisons la première
c'est que contribuer à fabriquer dans
l'espace du carburant c'est encourager
le réapprovisionnement en carburant des
objets spatiaux et des missions
spatiales donc c'est un c'est un élément
à développer vous enfin essayez de vous
imaginer votre voiture vous la
remplissez en moyenne de mémoire les
chiffres qu'on nous avait donné on va
dire plusieurs centaines de fois au
cours de sa vie un avion pareil on le
réapprovisionne en carburant un objet
spatial globalement on n'est pas
réapprovisionné il se lancer il a vite
vu sa vie au mieux on le désorbite et il
se désintègre et la mission est terminée
au mieux il se désintègre pas au mieux
il reste en orbite il a plus de
carburant et ça se transforme en débrie
mais l'enjeu à ce stade les objets
spatiaux sont parmi les seuls objets de
fabrication humaine non réapprovisionnés
en énergie au cours de leur vie c'est
c'est typiquement un discours qui n'est
pas tenable dans le cas d'une transition
climatique et dans le cadre de nos
engagements énergétiques donc développer
des technologies de fabrication de
carburant dans l'espace et on le précise
bien dans le Livre blanc on peut
commencer par tenter d'en produire
d'apprendre en tout cas en produire en
orbite basse réapprovisionné en orbite
basse et ensuite développer les
technologies qui permettront d'exploiter
les ressources de la lune pour fabriquer
du carburant néanmoins premier élément
donc contribuer à l'intégration de cette
possibilité de réapprovisionnement
carburant deuxième élément évidemment le
maximum de ressources fonctionnaient sur
la lune pour réapprovisionner des
missions spatiales c'est d'autant moins
de ressources ponctionnées sur la terre
pour remplir l'édit mission donc en
définitive ça permet de faire une
économie des ressources Terre-Lune le
dernier élément et c'est sans doute le
plus important dans une transition éner
terrestre qui reposerait sur
l'exploitation de l'hydrogène les
technologies développées pour lisse rue
sont à peu près les mêmes que celles qui
sont appliquées à terre catalyseurs
électrolyse d'utilisation de l'hydrogène
il y a donc dans le développement des
technologies distrus un effort commun
intéressant une continuité des
techniques et on parle là de la
transition énergétique du lendemain
immédiat et pas après-demain mais demain
pour faire un parallèle avec un autre
projet l'exploitation des ressources
enfin présentera sans doute ses premiers
bénéfices alors même quitter sur
lesquels on a investi une commencera de
même pas lui-même à présenter ses
premiers bénéfices énergétiques on parle
bien d'une exploitation des ressources
de demain alors certes 10 ans vous allez
nous dire pour le commun des mortels
c'est le début de la prospective c'est
le début de la temporalité prospective
pour le spatial disant c'est c'est après
demain voir demain même et enfin
j'aimerais quand même terminer par deux
éléments et ensuite en effet ce sera
sans doute intéressant de d'avoir
quelques questions puisque le sujet est
quand même très complexe
celui de l'encadrement juridique
parce que si je ne suis pas expert en
ressources spatiale néanmoins je reste
doctorant en droit spatial donc en
principe je suis sur un terrain un peu
plus familier que l'hydrogène et
l'oxygène produit à partir de
l'électrolyse et de catalyse mais
l'exploitation des ressources invite en
effet à considérer leur encadrement
juridique
parce que si la conquête spatiale qui
reprend et il ne faut pas être pudique
on parle vraiment de course à l'espace
entre les États-Unis et les Russes
chinois mon avantage la Chine mais on
parle bien d'un nouvel affrontement
presque Est-Ouest dans le spatial avec
un écart toujours important certes
Isabelle sorbetz Verget elle a mis en
avant la Chine a encore des échelles des
choses à rattraper mais néanmoins cette
affrontement aura lieu et a priori en
parallèle la guerre des grands traités
spatiaux n'est plus puisque depuis 1979
et l'échec de l'accord sur la lune le
dialogue multilatéral qui pourrait
aboutir à des grands traités sur
l'espace et au moins un compromis au
mieux impossible et la plupart des
juristes s'accordent à dire que
profitons-en pour conserver l'aquit des
grands traités spatiaux et ne les
remettons pas en négociation et
d'ailleurs quand les Américains ont
initié les accords Artemis
il contribuait de en quelque sorte à
renforcer cette logique de l'impossible
à corps multilatérale sur la Lune et sur
l'exploitation des ressources spatiales
et sur l'espace c'est fini il y a des
grands traités spéciaux attendons-nous
clairement là-dessus les accords Artemis
sindisés par les États-Unis ne sont pas
un accord multilatéral c'est au mieux
une constellation d'accords bilatéraux
dominée par les Américains par ailleurs
en quelque sorte si vous me permettez
une métaphore qui n'est pas qui ne
relève pas des stations essence il
s'agit presque comme si c'est presque un
contrat d'adhésion la marge de
négociation étant définitive
relativement limitée les Américains
apposent à leur partenaire une certaine
interprétation du droit de l'espace et
très globalement ils n'ont quasiment pas
leur mot à dire dessus
c'est même accords sont analysables
comme une certaine interprétation du
droit spatial international par la
puissance américaine on parlait tout à
l'heure du respect du traité de 67 de
fait constatons qu'au moment où les
accords Artemis sont sortis la plupart
des juristes de droit spatiales étaient
relativement choqués de l'interprétation
américaine contenue dans ces accords
Artemis de la non-appropriation des
ressources
ça c'était pour la doctrine de la part
des autres États la réaction était un
peu plus mitigée et sans doute que on
peut lire là du point de vue de la de la
perspective étatique
un élément intéressant c'est que pour la
plupart des partenaires des accords
Artemis la question de la propriété
remise sur la table la question de la
non-appropriation et peut-être devenu
obsolète et en définitive on est bien
dans une double conquête juridique de la
part des de la part des Américains et
des Chinois et les Chinois pour
l'instant sauf erreur de ma part et je
parle sous le contrôle d'Isabelle non
pas encore donné d'équivalents
d'interprétation juridique de ce qu'ils
entendaient comme étant le régime de
propriété des ressources néanmoins la
nouvelle conquête de la Lune est bien
une conquête du droit ce qui mène à un
dernier point celui de la France et nous
dans tout ça
les accords Artemis et
en définitive les accords Artemis
c'était tout à fait réalisables dans une
version européenne pourquoi est-ce que
les États européens se sont amies autour
de la table et ont décidé aurait pu
décider de faire un accord relativement
court imaginons une dizaine d'articles
qui auraient représenté une charte
d'engagement européen vers la lune on y
appelle dans le Livre blanc chapitre
gouvernance néanmoins sur la France
au-delà d'un accord européen type
Artémis j'aimerais revenir sur un
dernier point celui en effet mis en
avant par Pascal ultra Guerra qui est
celui d'une loi française sur les
ressources spatiales la France a signé
les accords Artemis en juin dernier ce
qui signifie quand même qu'elle s'engage
aux côtés des Américains dans un projet
Artemis qui a l'exploitation des
ressources au cœur du programme donc en
définitive ne pas se doter assez tôt ou
se doter trop tard d'une loi française
sur les ressources spatiales c'est
risqué d'être un partenaire Artémis qui
n'est pas doté d'une loi couvrant une
des applications principales du
programme donc armons-nous dès
aujourd'hui à la lumière notamment de
l'exemple luxembourgeois d'une loi
française sur les ressources spéciales
nous en avons besoin pour clarifier le
cadre être en scène une exploitation des
ressources également pour sécuriser un
environnement d'innovation en France
autour de ces mêmes ressources et enfin
pour attirer également des startups ou
des projets d'entreprises qui souhaitent
se centrer sur cette exploitation des
ressources et soyons fous visons même
une loi européenne sur les ressources
spatiales alors clairement l'article 189
du TFUE semble être une barrière
difficilement contournable puisque pour
le site et pour contribuer à la
réalisation des objectifs visés au
paragraphe 1 à une politique spatiale
européenne le Parlement européen et le
Conseil stature conformément la
procédure législative ordinaire etc etc
peuvent prendre toutes les mesures
nécessaires à l'exclusion de toute
harmonisation des dispositions
législatives et réglementaires des États
membres bon bah très bien dans ces
cas-là mettons-nous d'accord entre
partenaires et ça d'un accord
relativement limité de quelques articles
et ensuite gageons que chaque État
membre de Lisa Sora les insérer dans son
droit interne mais toujours est-il
Armand ou techniquement harmons-nous
économiquement et harmonie juridiquement
on est bien dans une nouvelle conquête
de la Lune l'urgence c'est de s'y
engager et s'y engager notamment parce
que cet affrontement Est-Ouest
États-Unis Chine a besoin d'une tierce
partie d'une tierce partie qui croit en
quoi en la durabilité en la science et
au progrès et cette tierce partie a des
valeurs d'apaisement du de
l'affrontement en tout cas Russo chinois
sur la lune gageons que l'Europe puisse
être une une puissance d'apaisement et
enfin dernier point j'aimerais également
rebondir sur ce camion en avant Clarisse
juste avant en effet nous avons besoin
de compétences et sans doute allez-vous
trouver le sujet très terrestre en
définitive après un exposé sur la lune
mais inquiétons-nous en tout cas de la
baisse de l'engagement des jeunes
lycéens dans les disciplines
scientifiques et mathématiques puisque
ces jeunes étudiants sont les ingénieurs
de demain alors peut-être que pour le
spécial 10 ans c'est demain mais 10 ans
c'est le temps de faire un doctorat pour
un étudiant qui passe son bac cette
année et dans 10 ans ce jeune doctorant
désormais docteur dans 10 ans sera sans
nul doute un talent européen à mettre au
service des ambitions spatiales
européennes comme quoi vous voyez le on
a beau parler de ressources lunaires ça
peut paraître être un sujet lointain les
enjeux sont immédiats et ils sont à
quelques mètres d'ici voilà
merci un grand merci à vos interventions
pour vos interventions pendant
respectives je suis passé sans plus
attendre la parole à Christine laarde
parce que je crois qu'elle a des
obligations afin qu'elles puissent vous
poser les premières questions et
derrière
oui je m'excuse par anticipation si je
dois vous quitter mais on a des
obligations beaucoup plus terre à terre
à savoir qu'on est toutes les demandes
de la commission des finances et qu'il y
a un nouvel loi de finances qui arrive
et on a l'audition du ministre à 10h
donc ça sera beaucoup moins passionnant
que tout ce qu'on a pu entendre ce matin
est vraiment merci beaucoup pour vos
quatre exposés très complets les uns les
uns avec les autres alors en fait à vous
écouter il y a deux questions qui me
viennent c'est aujourd'hui finalement
pourquoi l'Europe n'arrive pas à émerger
en tant que troisième puissance est-ce
que le problème vient du fait qu'on est
face à des blocs en Chine on a un parti
qui décide et tout le monde s'aligne aux
États-Unis on est à 1 et finalement en
Europe on est ni en plus on est dans une
configuration particulière à savoir que
lézard ce n'est pas l'Union européenne
on peut être dans l'Union européenne et
de peine dans les ailles on peut être
dans les uns pas être dans l'Union
européenne et donc elle sait à dire
qu'en fait aujourd'hui cette entité a
finalement 25 30 avis individuels qui
est difficile de faire converger
ensemble parce que les priorités ne sont
pas les mêmes et on voit bien que vous
l'avez dit très justement tout ça coûte
très cher et comment aujourd'hui on peut
justement arriver à
redonner cette envie ou faire converger
enfin on voit bien que par exemple les
Pays-Bas qui ont une inflation à plus de
20% comment est-ce qu'ils vont pouvoir
expliquer à leur population qu'il est
important de venir augmenter le budget
de l'agence pour répondre à des enjeux
de moyen terme qui pourront peut-être
derrière rapporter des richesses donc là
c'était ma première question
et la seconde elle porte sur la question
sur la question du droit et quand on
parle de de questions économiques et
vous l'avez bien dit il faut essayer
d'attirer les acteurs privés un acteur
privé pour s'engager il a besoin d'être
certain que ce qu'il va faire va être
protégé dans le temps et donc là on voit
bien qu'on est sur une sur un espace une
ressource dont on n'arrive pas à savoir
qui en est propriétaire et donc est-ce à
dire que c'est aujourd'hui le premier
qui arrive qui développera sa
technologie qui va tout capter ou est-ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui déjà des prémices
d'une sorte de régulation avec tous les
enjeux de développement durable et
durabilité que vous avez aussi exposé
c'est compliqué de négocier à plusieurs
mais en même temps ça doit être une
fierté européenne de dire qu'on coopère
à plusieurs états au sein de grands
projets spacieux européens alors certes
c'est plus compliqué pour la négociation
ça met plus de temps et budgétairement
ça mène parfois des négociations un peu
marchand de tapis mais néanmoins cette
fierté de pouvoir coopérer ensemble on
doit la conserver et c'est ça que ça
signifie finalement négociant en tant
qu'Européen pour aller dans l'espace et
le dernier point c'est peut-être sur le
la deuxième enfin la première question
ça devait être la oui c'était toujours
la première question juste pour pour la
donner donc c'est une donnée de la NASA
donc c'est à prendre avec quelques
pincelles puissant définitif c'est une
promotion du programme Artemis par la
NASA ou dans le cadre d'une étude
économique mais le programme Artemis ça
représente 37000 emplois aux États-Unis
ça fait quand même d'après la NASA ça
fait quand même 37000 personnes qui
touchent un salaire tous les mois grâce
au maintien du programme Artemis et puis
par ailleurs c'est 2 milliards en textes
revenus donc on est quand même sur 37000
emplois de milliards de taxes revenus
pour le programme Arte donc mine de rien
ça ça démontre enfin certes c'est
compliqué d'expliquer
à monsieur et madame tout le monde qu'on
va augmenter le budget européen du
spatial pour aller sur la Lune néanmoins
on peut leur mettre en avant que
l'investissement fait pour la Lune a des
bénéfices terriens immédiats on parle
bien d'emploi locaux on parle de PME qui
fabrique des câbles dans le sud de la
France jusqu'aux entreprises du CAC 40
le parle d'emploi locaux pas forcément
d'emplois dans quelques bassins spatiaux
que on parle de voilà de peu de PME qui
contribuent à fabriquer des engins qui
demain vont dans l'espace
peut-être juste avant que vous vous
interveniez laisser la parole
inapoliagen et puis vous répondrez parce
que je crois que sinon
merci monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup très sincèrement c'était
passionnant on aurait envie de vous
écouter toute la journée on ressort
moins bête de cette salle de réunion
j'avais une question une remarque est-ce
que vous pensez que
la commande publique européenne
notamment devrait être mobilisés en fait
pour permettre
un passage à l'acte finalement de ces de
ces acteurs que vous avez toutes enfin
tous évoqué pardon et puis je partage à
100% la la l'analyse qui est la vôtre de
l'avantage compétitif qui pourrait être
celui de l'Union
à privilégier le dual et la durabilité
en fait c'est notre seul moyen je pense
de retrouver une avance par rapport au
retard que l'on accuse dans ce domaine
et puis aussi d'être porteur enfin comme
on essaie de le faire
d'une approche éthique finalement de la
techno de la science etc
d'éclaircissement certains très très
terre à terre vous nous parlez donc de
l'enjeu européen et vous avez parlé
aussi de la singularité du Luxembourg je
voudrais savoir comment vous articuler
enfin comprendre un petit peu plus cette
cette particularité et puis après une
question
moi je suis un peu perdu dans dans
l'espace tellement c'est vaste vous nous
parlez après de conquête de l'infini et
de faire une une escale sur la lune pour
l'infini est-ce que c'est un enjeu à la
dimension ou bien est-ce qu'on peut
trouver sur terre des ressources et de
l'énergie future qui permettent
d'échapper cette à cette escale
Richard
me laisser présentation c'est que donc
nous voyons se développer
des projets technologiques scientifiques
économiques de grande ampleur dans une
certitude
d'un sécurité juridique
c'est à dire que
on est typiquement
dans la situation extrême de législation
extraterritoriale
des tas qui n'ont rigoureusement aucune
légitimité
pour prononcer ces normes
la seule base juridique fiable
puisse m'organiser et sécuriser ses
activités serait une base comparable au
traité de l'Antarctique
c'est-à-dire un traité universel
elle est très certainement hors
d'atteinte pour au moins une génération
et donc
l'ensemble des activités
touchant le corps lunaire va se faire
sous les régimes étaniques terrestres
qui autoproclame leur capacité à fixer
des normes sur un corps
céleste alors que n'importe quel autre
des 195 états des Nations Unies peut
émettre la même
prétention et que tout indique comme le
tableau tout à l'heure qui voyait
apparaître enfin qui présentait
l'arrivée de nouveaux partenaires de
nouveaux
intervenants que cette prétention à
légiférer va se démultiplier
donc
tout ça promet
un far west potentiellement prospère
pour les avocats et pour les assureurs
parce que bien entendu ça rendra
beaucoup plus incertaine et beaucoup
plus fragile le modèle économique de ces
opérations d'investissement qui sont
forcément lourdes et à long terme
ça nous arrêtera pas mais donc il y aura
besoin de se couvrir de multiples façons
face aux risques de concurrence non
régulée
alors bien sûr nous sommes en France
nous sommes au Sénat et donc on doit
certains d'entre nous nous sommes
vraiment européens
donc on doit faire le passage obligé par
l'engagement vers une contribution plus
forte de l'Union européenne mais
en l'occurrence je beaucoup de mal à
identifier ce que serait les éléments de
rapport de force et économique et
juridique qui permettrait à l'Union
européenne de jouer un rôle de Rennes
Blokker
et en fin Daniel Guéret pour une
dernière question et avant merci pour
prendre la parole votre exposé vos
exposés moi je
j'ai bien compris que dans votre exposé
vous nous avez bien expliqué que la
question n'était pas de savoir si on
irait un jour on ira un jour et de
savoir surtout ce qui l'Europe
participerait ou pas et alors justement
sur ce point dans vos différents exposés
que vous êtes j'imagine amené à faire
sur le territoire européen quel est
votre ressenti sur le degré de
mobilisation
bêta européen comme l'Allemagne par
exemple est-ce que on partage avec des
principaux pays européens quelques
pistes sur lesquelles on pourrait
s'engager pour promouvoir ou est-ce que
vous sentez que là aussi c'est un
géométrie variable ce qui expliquerait
d'ailleurs pour de large part le fait
que nous n'arrivions pas à se
positionner sur le plan de l'Europe
merci je vous aide à nouveau la parole
pour
puissiez répondre je sais pas qui
souhaitent débuter
comme vous souhaitez
oui pour revenir peut-être sur le
position de l'Europe au niveau
international sur ces sur ces questions
d'exploration ou d'exploitation des
ressources alors en fait le l'Europe
notamment à travers l'Agence spatiale
européenne a fait le choix un choix qui
me paraît assez comment dirais-je tout à
fait honorable de la coopération de la
coopération internationale donc
effectivement avec une capacité quand
même assez forte à coopérer finalement
pratiquement avec tout le monde bon avec
la Russie on l'a vu ça va plus être
possible là dans les dans les années qui
viennent mais en tout cas voilà donc
c'était le choix qui a été fait et
assumé quelque part donc on a eu le
principe par exemple des barteurs
s'agissant de de l'utilisation de de la
Station spatiale internationale l'idée
c'était de d'avoir un peu le même
dispositif dans le cadre par exemple de
de
des missions artemises sur la surface
lunaire ou avec le Gateway donc voilà
c'est l'idée c'est donc d'apporter des
briques à des missions d'envergure
internationale
est-ce qu'il faut demain effectivement
s'affranchir de de cet aspect
partenariat bon on a on a au jour
d'aujourd'hui une réflexion qui qui doit
comment enfin qui en tout cas qui a été
encouragé par le président Emmanuel
Macron de voir si l'Europe voulait se
doter d'une autonomie en matière de vols
habité pour l'orbite basse
on voit que rien que ça quand on quand
il y a des discussions anciens au sein
de l'Agence spatiale européenne ce type
d'approche ne fait pas l'unanimité donc
comment comment passer de de la
coopération internationale à la
souveraineté probablement qu'il faut pas
passer d'un extrême à un autre enfin
voilà il y a tout une réflexion qui qui
est en cours et qui n'est pas évidente à
mener
par ailleurs on parlait aussi tout à
l'heure du rôle de l'Union européenne
alors au jour d'aujourd'hui l'Union
européenne n'est pas très impliquée dans
ses affaires d'exploration de l'espace
c'est un territoire j'ai envie de dire
revendiquer par l'Agence spatiale
européenne donc l'Agence spatiale
européenne qui avec ses une certaine
façon aussi à certaines limitations
c'est une agence intergouvernementale de
R&D donc c'est c'est un effectivement
très une agence très forte pour elle a
réalisation et la participation à des
grands programmes spatiaux avec des
enjeux technologiques scientifiques etc
maintenant effectivement dès lors qu'on
commence à parler de dimensions
politiques de de règlement ou de loi
enfin de choses comme ça effectivement
là on voit bien que on ne pourra pas se
contenter entre guillemets de de passer
par l'Agence spatiale européenne on peut
effectivement avoir des discussions avec
nos partenaires mais mais la dimension
politique va exiger effectivement une
implication plus grande au niveau de au
niveau de l'Union européenne s'agissant
des pays européens
voilà peut-être je vais laisser mes
collègues complétés
et je remercie Pascal c'est vrai quand
la dualité esta Commission européenne
avec des enjeux des histoires
différentes et moi je salue évidemment
la présence de lézard qui qui dont il
faut garder le potentiel la dynamique le
périmètre mais c'est vrai et on le voit
bien avec notre commissaire Thierry
Breton il y a sûrement des dialogues des
modes de fonctionnement des intégrations
à adopter pour que il y ait une sorte de
coopération de méta gouvernance de cet
ensemble et de permettre d'impliquer
absolument tout le monde puisque vous
l'avez dit on a des frontières avec ces
organisations qui sont pas cohérentes
donc il faut chercher cette cette
cohérence là alors moi je suis pas une
spécialiste des gouvernances spatiales
de chaque État européen mais j'ai le
sentiment que l'Allemagne fait un
travail intéressant en mobilisant son
industrie privée du nom spatiale on
parle de robotique on parle de mobilité
et ça c'est à regarder de près c'était
regarder de près avec d'autres États qui
sont l'Italie aussi qui sont assez
présents et en dehors du spatial
historique c'est-à-dire des lanceurs etc
donc je nous invite vraiment et on nous
invite nous la NT à travailler avec les
entreprises du non spatial européen même
si parfois ça dépasse un peu notre
périmètre de légitimité et merci et
monsieur le sénateur Richard pour cette
déclinaison effectivement de cette
certitude d'y aller dans un contexte
incertain alors c'est souvent le cas en
R&D on fait bien des choses dans une
forme de certitude de trouver un vaccin
ou sous-enteur de la technologie ou la
science peut tout dans des contextes de
grande incertitude et c'est là où on
voit qu'il faut se mettre ensemble et je
finis généralement mes éditos ensemble
parce que c'est ça qui peut limiter les
risques que vous avez décrits et et bien
sûr on est dans une limitation
certainement pas une absence d'une levée
complète des risques sachant qu'en plus
on vit dans l'incertitude des
comportements humains des choix
politiques qui ont le voit en ce moment
rien n'est acquis
on convient voilà bah je vais je vais je
vais laisser ma parole à mes camarades
oui j'aimerais juste répondre sur les
aspects juridiques et sur les
incertitudes
de fait la privatisation et la
commercialisation des activités
spatiales c'est fait dans un cadre
juridique relativement produit par
l'industrie dans la mesure où les lois
spatiales nationales sont plutôt
généralement une déclinaison des
engagements pris dans les traités donc
surveillance autorisation d'opération
immatriculation etc et donc on constate
quand même trois grands traits dans le
droit des activités spatiales privées à
savoir un recours quasi systématique à
l'arbitrage une importance de la source
contractuelle dans le droit spatial et
le troisième élément qu'il y a avec le
new space une diversification des
sources de capitaux enfin des sources de
financement notamment via les vinscher
capital et autres donc on constate quand
même que
les investisseurs savent en tout cas
être relativement rassurés par la façon
dont le droit spatial s'opère
aujourd'hui donc moi ce que je vais
mettre en avant c'est que gageong sur la
Lune en réalité le droit privé spécial
face à une négociation du droit public
interétatique spatiale s'agissant de la
lune relativement freinée ou en tout cas
plus multilatéral gajons que ce cette
régulation contractuelle cette
régulation des assurances et autres
réussira à trouver sa souplesse
suffisante sur la question en fin du de
la propriété dans l'espace moi je en ce
moment pour tout vous dire je
m'intéresse beaucoup à l'histoire
juridique de la conquête du nouveau
monde et il y a eu au moment c'est le
sujet arrive il y a eu un au moment où
on est arrivé dans le Nouveau Monde donc
l'utilisation d'un recours issu du
second traité du gouvernement civil de
Locke à savoir que les indigènes ne
travaillant pas leur terre puisque à
l'époque selon les colons c'était des
chasseurs-cueilleurs donc ces indigènes
ne travaillant pas leur terre ils
n'avaient aucun titre de propriété ni de
souveraineté sur le territoire sur
lequel les colons arrivaient et en
définitive on va sans doute se retrouver
avec une relative analogie s'agissant de
la lune à savoir que le premier utilisé
le site d'atterrissage sera celui qui
bénéficiera d'un droit exclusif sur ce
territoire et tant pis pour les autres
et en réalité sans doute que le débat
sur la propriété
spatial et la propriété des ressources
aurait pu être plus apaisé toujours
compliqué mais plus apaisé si les
Américains n'avaient pas glissé dans les
accords Artemis cette histoire de
selfizomes puisqu'en définitive il est
là le problème essentiel
sans doute vous êtes tous et toutes
familier après la métaphore sur le
Nouveau Monde une métaphore plus
contemporaine celle sur le camping mais
dans un camping un mobil-home est
présent sur le terrain du mobil-home
pourtant vous n'êtes pas propriétaire du
terrain sous-jacent à votre mobil-home
vous êtes juste propriétaire du
mobil-home mais pas du terrain sur
lequel il est posé on peut sans doute se
retrouver dans la même situation dans
l'espace à savoir une non propriété du
territoire sous-jacent le module mais
une utilisation néanmoins exclusive de
ce territoire sous-jacent donc l'enjeu
il est sans doute là ça sert à rien
d'essayer de développer des titres de
propriété pour un carré de la lune
néanmoins à ce stade l'enjeu il est de
réfléchir aux questions de plus de
propriété intellectuelle et propriétés
des découvertes d'ailleurs faites à
partir de de ses ressources et j'en
terminerai là moi ce qui me plairait ce
serait de savoir dans la déclinaison des
différents accords Artemis ce qu'elles
ont été les accords passés sur
l'immatriculation
des objets spatiaux utilisés des
activités spatiales puisqu'il y a des
enjeux de propriété intellectuels
immédiat et eux sont beaucoup plus
urgents que les enjeux de propriété du
sol
tout à fait
je peux juste finir sur le Luxembourg
vous posiez la question la question du
Luxembourg Luxembourg et membre de
lézard et donc une partie est de son
activité justement sur les ressources
planétaires et cette idée de la
motivation vient du Luxembourg
l'originalité c'est qu'il a été le
premier à suivre la loi américaine sur
la commercialisation des ressources et
donc il a très vite émis une loi dans
lequel il invitait toutes les sociétés
qui seraient domiciliées au Luxembourg
en leur en lui apportant le garant
finalement de la loi luxembourgeoise en
tant qu'État puisque ce sont les États
qui sont membres partis du traité de 67
donc en réalité quand vous avez une
activité dans l'espace elle doit être
adossée à la responsabilité d'un état et
le Luxembourg proposé d'ouvrir justement
des sociétés intéressées après on a bien
vu que planétari ressources je crois que
c'était son nom exactement fait faillite
enfin c'est pas du tout le domaine
d'Alban est effectivement une vraie
question dans la dimension spatiale et
en plus au Luxembourg il y avait
vraiment cette idée de de garder une
continuité entre justement la ressource
minière qui les a enriches la ressource
financière qui a stabilisé et cette
projection dans dans le futur avec de
l'innovation en fait donc rejoindre à la
fois des enjeux d'ingénieurs de
technologie etc de lisibilité européenne
et éventuellement de business
la question de la commande publique donc
effectivement
je dirais il y a plusieurs possibilités
qui sont pas d'ailleurs exclusives d'une
part il y a effectivement le fait de
devoir faire maturer un secteur émergent
autour de ces activités lunaires avec en
plus comme l'a très bien expliqué
Clarisse en juillet le fait d'avoir
aussi un retour sur les activités
terrestres donc là c'est c'est
l'objectif aussi des inducateurs comme
text the moon auquel le CNES participent
avec mubo donc là voilà c'est pour faire
émerger ce tissu économique après il y a
effectivement la question de de faire
des passer des contrats et d'avoir de la
commande publique vers ces acteurs et là
là on est plutôt effectivement dans Ça
c'est plutôt au niveau de l'ESC ça peut
se passer puisque comme on l'a très bien
dit ces activités là ont quand même une
dimension européenne
indispensable pour vu l'ambition du
sujet et donc là effectivement on
encourage beaucoup les uns à passer des
contrats avec ces acteurs émergents
s'agissant donc des activités
d'exploration et pas seulement
d'ailleurs ça va au-delà de
l'exploration comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer
voilà je sais pas si par ailleurs
mes collègues veulent compléter sur les
autres
très bien bah écoutez à moins que les
collègues et encore d'autres questions
complémentaires sinon
il nous reste à vous remercier pour ces
échanges passionnants riches et qui
appellent bien sûr
beaucoup d'autres questions par rapport
aux travaux qui qui sont là en tout cas
merci encore une fois de ces éclairages
pour nous ils sont ils sont
véritablement précieux d'autant plus
précieux que je le disais on préambule
c'est un sujet qui sent mauvais jeu de
mots n'a jamais été réellement exploré
y compris dans cette dimension
prospective ici au Sénat et donc nous
aurons certainement encore à échanger
sur sur ces questions dans les dans les
semaines à venir en tout cas un grand
merci de votre participation et puis
excellente journée à toutes et à tous
merci